DAN GALPIN: I'm Dan Galpin,
Android Developer Advocate
here at Google.
This is Android Tool
Time, and we're here
with Android Studio 2.2.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[ALARM CLOCK RINGING]
At Google I/O this year, we
previewed Android Studio 2.2,
promising a host of new
features and improvements.
After testing and
integrating your feedback
during the preview
and beta phases,
we're happy to announce that
Android Studio 2.2 is now
available for download
in the stable channel.
Android Studio 2.2
offers improvements
for all phases of app creation--
prototyping and interface
design, code development
and iteration, and testing
and debugging.
Let me walk you through
some of those changes.
We revamped the Layout Editor
and added built-in support
for constraint layout,
an entirely new way
to build dynamic user interfaces
on Android in a visual way
by specifying view
positions and constraints.
The Layout Editor features a new
blueprint mode and an attribute
panel for changing the
visual attributes of widgets
so you won't have to jump
into text mode as often.
And for when you need
to debug your UI,
we have a new layout
inspector that
lets you capture a snapshot of
the hierarchy and attributes
as they run on a
device or emulator.
We're continually
improving the Code Editor,
bringing you better
code analysis with new
and updated lint checks.
You can now also
simply right click
to search across all
our samples on GitHub
when you need to consult
Android sample code
for the proper usage of an API.
And we've upgraded
to IntelliJ 2016.1
with all its enhancements,
such as right
to left language support and
method argument reordering.
Thanks to the
Firebase integration,
you can now easily add Firebase
services, like analytics,
Cloud Messaging, and crash
reporting to your apps,
including initial project
setup and adding dependencies.
We include handy documentation
links and code snippets
that you can add to your app
to get the Firebase features up
and running quickly.
To better understand
what happens
to your manifest during
merging, you can now
use the Merged Manifest Viewer.
This lets you
preview the manifest
as it will look after the
build with contributions
from other manifest files
in libraries highlighted
in different colors.
For developers who want
to examine the finished
content of their APK,
we've built a new APK
analyzer in Android Studio.
By simply opening
your app's APK,
you will be able to inspect
how much space each component
of your app takes up along with
an estimated download size,
even taking into account any
compression applied by the Play
Store.
With the compare feature,
it's easy to analyze
APK size regressions relative to
previous versions of your app.
You can also debug
Multidex issues
by drilling down
into classes.dex
as well as explore the
contents of resource files.
Anyone working with native
code in libraries will be happy
to hear that we've added support
for C and C++ projects using
the CMake and NDK build systems.
Now you can seamlessly import
your native project in Android
Studio and take advantage of
the many improvements we've made
to editing and debugging
C and C++ code in the IDE.
For those working with
OpenGLES directly,
we're including a beta version
of a new GPU debugger which
records GL commands at runtime
and lets you replay and fully
inspect the GL
state in each frame
and after each
instruction, including
the contents of the buffers,
textures, and meshes.
We're still working on a few
features for the GPU debugger,
as well as improvements to
its speed and stability, which
is why it's marked as beta.
Please give us feedback on this
new tool through the Android
Studio Google+ community
in Bug Tracker.
With this release
of Android Studio,
we're letting developers try
out our new tool for creating
UI tests for your
apps-- the Espresso Test
Recorder, also in Beta.
The Test Recorder works by
recording your interactions
with the app within the emulator
and letting you add assertions
in a simple interface.
The generated tests are
just plain Java code
using the Espresso library,
so you can customize them
later if needed.
The release of
Android Studio 2.2
coincides with
the 25.2.2 updates
to the SDK Tools and
Android emulator.
The emulator now lets you
simulate several Android
sensors, such as the
accelerometer, magnetometer,
ambient temperature, and
more within the emulator UI,
including a 3D
representation of the device
that you can move about.
As always, the
newest Android Studio
brings many other
under-the-hod improvements,
such as fixes to Instant
Run, build time improvements,
support for annotation
processors in the Jack
compiler, new app packaging
code, and better accessibility
supporting the IDE.
To make sure you get the most
of this version of Studio,
remember to update your projects
to use the 2.2.0 version
of our Android Gradle plugin.
Update your build
tools and emulator
images using the SDK
Manager, and make
sure to enable Instant Run.
I think that you'll enjoy the
many new features and stability
improvements in
Android Studio 2.2.
And as always, we're looking
forward to your feedback.
[MUSIC PLAYING]